so I've got the property bug and I was
sort of interested in properties and I
was living in not a great house and I
was looking to move out and then the
landlord when he found out I was looking
to move out wanted to sell it and I
thought this is an opportunity and it
just didn't stack as a deal happened to
mention it to you next thing I know
you're like I'm buying the house that
you live in I'm gonna be your landlord
you got me into property but I was like
probably your first student before you
were even teaching I used to get paid 25
pounds per show that I did and I was
probably doing about five shows a week
very bad you went from nothing to a
multi-millionaire the other thing I
wouldn't be able to buy a house and you
were like I found your house I hadn't
even seen it is it true that you went to
visit family around Lichfield and you
couldn't find a hotel you thought forget
this I'm never gonna have this happen to
be getting so you just bought a house
that's true yeah
that's gangster you know
foreign
[Music]
ERS on a Wednesday no problem it's very
rare that people can listen to you for
half an hour or so and just hear the
wisdom and what you've done you went
from nothing to a multi-millionaire in a
relatively short space time you're how
old now 33 33 you're my elder brother
and we're also business partners so why
don't you just give a little bit of
backstory about what you're doing right
now in the property business and how
you've made millions of pounds well
right now we're heavily focusing on
development so we've got eight sites
that we're currently building we've got
sites in Leeds we've got option
agreements we've got Eagle Works where
we're converting 48 Apartments just put
another pre-apping on that same site
actually trying an extra 15 apartments
on there as well so a lot of development
stuff really making a lot of money for
development also got a lot of buy to let
properties service accommodation hmos
real sort of mixed bag so out of all the
different properties that you've done
because you've been involved in a lot of
properties in different areas as well up
north in the Midlands and now more
recently mostly in buckinghamshire in
London what would you say your favorite
strategy is and why well definitely
right now my favorite strategy is
development I really I think that with
Development A lot of people diss
landlords out there landlords are kind
of oh greedy landlords take up the
housing etc etc with development
can't see how you're doing anything
other than serving the whole Community
we've got a housing shortage that you're
helping solve you're providing housing
for people that need it you're bringing
down property prices if anything because
you're creating more Supply so I just
think it's a fantastic it's good for the
economy it's not for everything and I
think as well with development you're
also talking about not just building
houses but also restoring houses buying
rundown properties converting them into
apartments or converting them to people
for family homes so if you look at
ribsford and Eagle works for example
that are working at the moment they're
two buildings that have been abandoned
that are going to rack and ruin Eagle
works is in a city center it's a bad
look to have abandoned buildings and
returning it reusing it into into
housing I think it's I think it's
fantastic so how did you get into
property and what was your first
property purchase and when did you buy
it so you got me into property you were
I was like probably your first sort of
student before you were even teaching
and you were like dude you've got to get
into property more like you know in
family when when you do something good
and we do this in our family when
someone's onto something they drag all
the other family into it and and now
everybody in our family it's just the
siblings in-laws you know wives
for example everyone's moved to
buckinghamshire yes our family is very
like that if one of us does one of us
goes to the gym yeah suddenly everyone
goes for this so I was more like the the
passionate brother that was learning
along along the way but just like dude
come and join me in there you were and
and I I was kind of interested but I was
I wasn't doing particularly well
financially at the time I was working
for Dad I I used to get paid 25 pounds
per show and I was probably doing about
five shows a week six seven hundred
pound a month very bad pretty poor yeah
I mean with inflation and stuff now it's
it's still terrible but it's not it's
not quite as terrible as it's probably
the equivalent to about 1200 1300 a
month minimum wage and all I was saying
to you you need to get into property
what did you think did you think are you
nuts why are you trying to get me to buy
a house I can't even well this other
thing I wouldn't be able to buy a house
and you were like found your house I
remember I remember it oh did I find it
yet you found me the house I hadn't even
seen it
I didn't even remember that yeah yeah
and I structured it as a no money down
deal it was I got a loan from Sheila for
for the money yeah so it wasn't making
me any profit and you also got a um a
high mortgage on it you got a 90
mortgage
um got a loan for the for the rest of
the department consent to let consent
alert and then I was paying it off and
the rent was covering paying back Sheila
and paying back the mortgage yeah and I
made about 50 Quid a month but then I I
spent that I didn't know I didn't even
know what ground rent was or service
charge like they're going to because it
was it's a leasehold Mason there and
they got in touch with me and they were
like you owe us was not very much it's
about 300 quid for the Year yo and I was
like
for what but it's my house and they were
like no for this for the service Charter
I don't it was like reading through like
sorting the leaves I remember what my
leaves I remember you ringing me up and
saying do I have
pay this service charger is it like the
service when you go out for a meal and
they put an extra service charge and I
was like no you have to say is this
optional like can I go and clean my own
leaves
yeah oh we're painting the door this
year what I didn't want you to paint my
door but yeah you know but that's what
an apartment it's a lease old property
and unless you have the Freehold you're
gonna have to pay a service charge I
realize that now yeah by the time I
didn't so and so my 50 pound profit
basically went on the on the service
charge but I mean I've had that property
now about 12 13 yes so you've been in
property for you know over a decade over
a decade now and the same tenant still
there wow I haven't changed the tenant
it's just and Brilliant and the property
museum is going to fall on value I've
refinanced it pulled them on pulled on
my your money or my money I had the
investors back I'd already paid it off
actually yeah so I just pulled a load of
money out so that was your first deal
and it was a no money down deal it was
it wasn't super profitable what happened
next so then I started getting involved
in hmos I started managing other
people's HR a set of the
um quick move which is my management
company it's quite a successful lighting
agent saying it was good it was good I
mean I was making most of my money from
entertainment at the time I had an
entertainment agency but I sort of
realized I mean both we were very we
used to coach one another and we used to
like meet up once a week I don't know if
you can I'm sure you can yeah of course
we do it once a week and then we'd go
right what are you doing your business
what am I doing my business and we'd
talk about bounce ideas off and we were
all the whole way through we were making
a very similar amount of money but what
I realized is I was working a lot harder
than you like all your money was just
sort of turning up at your house and I
even though I had a business and I had
staff at the time as we were growing I
was like working like really hard and
you you weren't I was like ah we're
making like he's making really good
money
and doing very little with the property
stuff and just to defend myself a little
bit Yeah at this point I was full-time
at bible college yeah I was also doing
trips charity trips I'm not saying I'm
not saying you were just dosing around
on a beach or a lazy I'm just saying for
your the money that was coming in you
weren't doing very much work right and a
lot of it was passive and I although I
was making similar money to you I was
kind of a little prominentalist at the
time but a little bit jealous of of how
it was coming in so that made me want to
get into property more I want to look at
strategies like service accommodation
but talk about the house that um your
landlord offered you you know the story
yes I got the property bug and I was
sort of interested in properties and I
was living in a um not a great house at
the time and I was looking to move out
and then the landlord when he found out
I was looking to move out wanted to sell
it and I thought oh this is an
opportunity looking to sell off Market
which isn't sold yet so I went and had a
chat with him and he told me how much he
wanted for it and it just didn't stack
as a deal you know I was working out my
return on investments I did all the
figures I thought now this this deal
doesn't work and I happen to mention it
to you in passing I remember oh oh even
for sale it doesn't work as a deal it's
off Market he tried to talk to me it
didn't really work and you you were like
that could be interesting I was like no
no no bro it's it's not it's not
interesting it's offline you're like
okay fair enough next thing I know
you're like I'm buying the house that
you live in I'm gonna be your landlord
well I moved out before that happened
but you're not I'm buying this and I was
like mate it doesn't stack bro you know
and you're like yeah but I'm not
paying anything for it I was on a lease
option agreement a what and I was like
wow you know when you when you realize
there are these strategies like the
lease option agreement that you did and
it's I think it's knowing the strategies
and being aware for the opportunities
when you're aware of lease options when
you're aware of what would work a
service accommodation what would work as
a commercial conversion for development
and you know you start seeing these
opportunities everywhere I'm sure you've
noticed as well in beckinsville you know
it's all banks are closing yeah I have
and I'm like hmm could these be Flats
yeah you know especially the one on uh
the Barclays okay so there's definitely
opportunities there but if you don't
know you don't see it yeah so I think
it's important that you know about lease
options you know about service
accommodation hmos BRS so you can spot
these opportunities when you're out and
about yeah that's brilliant so you saw
me buy your landlord's house yeah the
thing is I always see when someone's
trying to sell the house but they're
also good on for rent that's when I see
an opportunity well
at least option agreement because they
want to sell it but they don't need the
money now because they're happy to rent
it so I say well hang on why don't I
just take it off your hands I'll buy it
off you in seven years time and in the
meantime I'll give you a small
peppercorn rent you've got re released
from the property because usually those
people are tired landlords I don't know
people are just sick of the house yeah
and that's what I did with your landlord
and he sold it to me and I still own it
and ironically I think I've got the
still the same tenants and that was
years ago what did you think when you
looked at my business plan and you saw
all the rents that had coming in because
I wasn't like when I was like 21 22 I
was at Barber College full-time I was
also running training Kings which was
taking up a lot of my time so I wasn't
super busy on my property business but I
was making about what six seven Grand a
month in in rent when I was like I
remember where we came from as well so
you know we want I don't think at that
stage either of us will we wanted to be
successful we enjoyed it we had the bug
property but I don't think either of us
had aspirations to be like a
multi-millionaire or to live where we
live now want to drive the cars for me I
would see a new bill to stay house
three-bedroom my dream home I remember
you telling me that the range were
revoked was your dream car yeah our
dream was to live on the Turnberry yeah
in Block switch and we'd see these
detached three bed houses that were
worth about 250 Grand and we'd be like
man when we're in our 40s and 50s
imagine if we can live on that estate in
box switch Yeah that's why I kind of
think of vision boards I think vision
boards are good and stuff but like I
don't think you have to have the vision
now your situation changes very very
quickly so why don't long term goals
because how the hell do I know what I
want to be doing in 10 years time look
what we were doing 10 years ago I think
you want to be doing short-term goals
and just doing it really really quick
because you're always and the world's
changing as well everything's changing
all the time so it's sort of adapting to
that are entrepreneurs born or are they
made I believe that they are made I read
a very good book by a guy called Matthew
side who was uh called Bounce and bounce
is about the myth of talent and and the
and the sort of the facts I suppose of
hard work and putting hard work in I
think there's I think some of its
personality I think a big thing is
risk-taking I've always been a big risk
taker even when I was broke so I
remember when I was working for dads I
was probably thinking about a grand at
this stage a month and Anna was working
for Mark Spencer she hated it hated the
people hated the you know some of it not
all the people but I hate a lot of the
people the managers and stuff hated it
and she was just miserable there and I
was like [ __ ] it just leave
I'll figure out we'll figure something
out if you hate it just leave and I
wasn't a big believer in that I would
never put myself in a situation where I
was stuck being miserable just because I
need the money I'd rather just sort it
figure it out later so I think risk
taking is a big a big thing I think
that's
it's difficult to teach someone to
become a risk taker because you kind of
what you either are or you or your aunt
yeah uh but I definitely think you can
learn to be a business owner I think you
can learn to be an entrepreneur I think
you can learn the skills you I've always
loved my property business and we're now
business partners and we do all of our
property deals together and we've been
extremely successful because I think
you've got a real skill for
systemization and when I got to my
property business to a certain point I
think when we partnered I was at that
point because that was only what about
four four years ago or so so yeah five
years ago five years ago so at that
point you know I was a millionaire and I
was making pretty good money and you
partnered with me on the property stuff
and that but you did try and get me to
quit doing training I did you didn't
want me doing YouTube videos you didn't
want me doing training you didn't want
me doing any coaching and you're very
passionate about that as well and you
know
it's it since then it's not like a aha I
told you it's a moment but you know
together we've grown a massive training
business and it's the biggest property
training company in the UK
why did you try and get me to not do
training and do you looking back think
that you were wrong no I don't think I
was wrong I don't think I was right or
wrong I think it's I think it's about I
think there's sort of two aspects to
business so first of all I think one is
your is how much do you enjoy it your
mission your purpose as well as is it
making money I think there's different
aspects to take into consideration and
for me training wasn't really that I
mean I do a little bit of training and
stuff but it's not like oh I have to get
out there and I'll do it if it was if it
was free I'd still want to do it you
know what I mean like if I wasn't
getting paid whereas for you I think you
were happy to do it when you were
getting paid well well you were so you
were running training training Kings
which is like networking and stuff and I
remember sitting down looking at you
with you I was like dude
this business will never make any money
you know what the way that you're the
way that you're running it and you're
like yeah man but
that's what I want to do it's what I
believe in is what I want to help people
do that
when you said that fair enough if that's
the thing fair enough but I didn't think
it was gonna ever make any any money the
other thing is like it's very hard
systemized when people are buying you
so like with you you're the trainer they
come to see you it's not like a product
that you can that you can sell
so it's very hard to systemize it for
service isn't it really but it's but
it's not even just a service so my
entertainment business was a service
they weren't buying Russell Leeds they
were buying the entertainment agency and
therefore I could send different
entertainers
and I could systemize it right I could
it didn't matter if Russell Lee didn't
answer the phone it didn't matter if
Russell leads to go to the events with
you and the way you run your training
business it's all about Samuel leads and
when people come they want a piece of
you and I was just thinking long term if
everyone's taken yeah from you it's
quite a lot and it's the only business
that we've not systemized but we can't
systemize it because they want you and I
do give my time up and I spend a lot of
time mentoring and training
but if you love it you know people say
if you enjoy it you'll never work a day
in your life yeah I just think you need
to be careful because at times I think
you do too much so I think it's just a
bit of a balancing act but I'm very
happy with the training business now and
the way that we whether we're running it
yeah and and and I think that training
is a business where if you do it for the
money you're going to end up lasting six
months whereas if you do it because
you're very successful and you genuinely
want to help people and even the playing
field of course it's a business yeah you
know we charge we do we do a lot of our
stuff for free and again you were like
you need to charge for the crash course
and it's nuts I'm like all right
compromise is a pound
you know but I think I think for me it's
a mission I think you've seen part of
that mission you've been out to Uganda a
lot and you've seen the the success
students and also not just the
Fulfillment from that but you partner a
lot with the students so we're trying
people talk a little bit about like um
property [ __ ] well some of the perks
actually of running a training business
that you don't really think about is you
do get loads of opportunities loads of
joint venture opportunities everyone
wants to work with you everyone wants to
pass you deals invest with you so from a
networking point of view it's very good
yeah uh property pitch was fun some
people said to me like oh look you guys
trying to be like driving genuinely we
want that is how we would actually be if
someone was pitching us a deal we
weren't trying to be anything that's it
wasn't a show we genuinely were doing it
and we just thought we might as well
film it yeah yeah I mean obviously the
dramatic music is we wouldn't play that
when they walked in
but but how we were and how that's the
sort of questions that we'd ask and we
obviously went analog to the deals that
was fun I enjoyed that it was it was how
do you spend your money because you make
a lot of money so I like cars so I've
got two very nice cars that cost quite a
lot of money what do you drive I drive a
G-Wagon and a Porsche taken nice so I've
got one that's very environmentally
friendly and one that I think it evens
the playing field
same as me though right I've got my my
topography Range Rover and then I've got
my Mercedes which is electric that's
true that's true so yeah very simple is
it we can is it for the environment or
is it just because it's tax deductible
maybe for another day
but yeah it's just a good car it's
actually everything so I like that I
also like eating out I spent quite a lot
of money on sort of food experiences
when we were younger we couldn't afford
to eat out and now we can't afford it in
a different way mate oh no tell me about
it so it's you're a bad influence on me
when it comes to food for sure what is
it that drives you because we will often
say this like we might make a million
pounds on a deal and we're like oh my
God that's amazing but actually it
doesn't affect our everyday lives we
don't go we made a million pounds profit
last week so let's pay ourselves more
this month us we pay ourselves a salary
from our property business and even if
we have a back like during covert when
we first went into lockdown it was a bit
like crap because what's going on but we
just consistently got after it didn't
actually affect us no he didn't no he
didn't so what is it that drives you
because it's certainly not I mean you
know yes we enjoy nice things but we
don't spend I mean if you don't mind me
asking how much do you pay yourself as a
salary so I
I've worked this out actually recently
because it's it's we're having to work
out the tax sort of situation and
everything like that's taking everything
into consideration
it's about half a million a year okay
but technically your salary is probably
only 12 and a half Grand my salary
there's dividends and there's perks and
other stuff but yeah if you if you
factor it all in and work it out as if I
was an employee that was getting taxed
that's getting taxed on that's how much
it would cost would you have ever
thought 10 years ago that you'd be
paying yourself a salary of half a
million pounds a year no
I wouldn't do you think that's a bit
greedy
no
well how do you justify it because I
it's very simply actually similar to you
being you know a um a Christian and very
much a case of when you when you when we
were growing up it was don't because you
don't take too much but I just made a
commitment to give a percentage of
everything that I earn to to charity
into good causes what is that percentage
so it's 10 so everything that you make
you give 10 of the profits away yeah and
then you think well the more I'm making
myself the more I'm giving away
and growing up I remember that like when
we used to sleep on the floor with some
pretty poor we're gonna have carpets for
years do you remember yeah we didn't
grow up wealthy what do you think why do
you think we've both been so successful
just from a normal regular work and
family home I do you know I don't really
quite know I can't quite put my finger
on what what it was I don't know whether
I don't think we got given a lot Dad I
think was very hard on us and put us in
difficult situations like working for
him as an Entertainer when I was 16 I
was shy I don't know whether that helped
I also don't think we were ever given
anything we had to manage our own money
even when we were teenagers we had to
buy our own clothes we were given 10
pound a week and then that was for our
pocket money and our clothes and
anything we wanted we got given nothing
so we learned how to manage our money
and stuff from an early age as well yeah
we both worked hard both had multiple
paper rounds and we were children and um
and did other entrepreneurial activities
like even remember when we were like
we were living in Perth and so we must
have been
seven oh I wasn't you probably five and
going out watching people's cars yeah
taking a bucket and sponge I remember
people paying us to clean their wheel
they're like don't wash the car
but just watch the wheels here's 20
pence and I'll give you 50p and we're
like oh sucker I'm like but actually
it's because he doesn't want his car
wrecked it really is really has been
really compassionate really compatible
to a five and seven year old but even
then we were hungry for it weren't we
like why would a five-year-old want to
go washing cars because we had nothing
maybe we weren't giving anything well
maybe who knows are you worried about
the property Market because I know a few
years ago when we first started really
killing our property business
you and I had a conversation with Grant
Cardone and we said that you know what
happens if it all goes away what if the
market changes like drastically and
there was a little bit of a concern do
you ever worry that the market might
massively change I mean it has it is
with interest rates and does that ever
worry you uh not really for a few
reasons I think it's pretty much
accepted that they go up over time so
they go up and down and up and down but
overall they're going up so let's say
the property prices drop right now all
that means is we can't sell them and
we're gonna have to wait for them to go
back up I don't think I still think
they'll go back up I don't think we'll
it's not like Bitcoin we don't know we
might put our money into Bitcoin it
drops to nothing that's not gonna happen
it's land it's bricks and mortar it's a
physical asset so I'm not worried about
that you're not worried about your net
worth shrinking because you know that
it's in bricks and more it might shrink
but it'd be a good time to buy more
right shrinking which is what we're
doing right now exactly I've just been
on some viewings today what about rents
though what about interest rates going
up commercial properties dropping in
rental value
um talk to me a bit about super rent
number one commercial properties
dropping it's another opportunity right
so that's that's not a worry in fact if
anything that's a exciting right super
rant we talk about service accommodation
hmos
the properties that we're renting out if
we're doing it as a buyer there then
yeah I might be a bit concerned that I
might be losing a bit of money on
individual properties whatever but like
if we take for example what I bought
recently uh the house in Litchfield I
mean I made three grand profit last
month and it's a tiny house and it would
be renting out at 800 pound a month if
it was a normal house oh give me the
figures on that little house because
that's just one that you did because it
was an emotional you just thought I like
the house and and it happened to say I'd
like to be able to stay in Lichfield is
it true that you went to visit family
around Lichfield and you where you want
to stay in Lichfield and you couldn't
find a hotel
and you thought forget this I'm never
gonna have this happen to me again so
you just bought a house in Litchfield
for you really that's true yeah
that's gangster you know I mean going to
a city being like oh I can't get a hotel
this is annoying power we'll buy a house
like that is Gangster I didn't know for
sure whether it was going to work a
service so what I was thinking is I'll
buy it then I can use it whenever we
want we have a second time but it's got
loads of cupboards and stuff so we can
store a lot of stuff there a bit of a
second cupboards sorry so like what
something is like if we're traveling if
you have to take anything with me it's
just there right which I like right
because I'm gonna think about it just
turn up and I thought sorry who buys a
house because there's a lot of cupboards
hopefully you're gonna say something
really you know the area is right near
the cathedral no there's a lot of
coverage do you know what it was the
area though because I I like it's it's
literally is a city albeit a very small
you know what I think I think that
you've always when we were broke living
in Warsaw Lichfield was the closest city
that was nearby us that was really Posh
and I think you've secretly always
wanted to live in Litchfield I have
lived in Litchfield we used to live in
Litchfield it wasn't really Litchfield
there was it just on it just on the
outside anyway go on so we got the house
um it rents out really really well
ironically we don't use it that much now
we used it quite a bit how much are the
market payments the interest interest is
799 so you pay 799 a month and then
you're renting how much profit are you
making generally every month on it so I
mean that's what was a really good month
I made about three grand profit normally
about Grands or half grams and a half
but if you did that as a single there
you'd make no profit but that's also
including pay off the mortgage it's not
interest only oh so you made three grand
last month and you're also paying the
mortgage back slowly as well oh mate
that's awesome so it's more than three
grand then so well that was last month
normally it's probably it's probably
about I'll probably make a gram and a
half yeah and then you're paying down
the mortgage slowly and also with
interest rates we fixed them didn't
wages before they just but even if the
interest rate is doubled
how many making yeah a grand this is why
I think you also took a business partner
to work with because you can constantly
always looking at Solutions rather than
problems so you're always looking at if
there's if the house prices drop you go
great time to buy everyone's scared you
know so you're always seeing the
opportunities not seeing the problems
and also I'm always predicting what do
you what do you think how freaky am I
predictions because every time I predict
something's about to happen in the
property Market come on well we had a
conversation about uh a year ago and you
were saying I want to work out the
mortgage interest rates at six percent I
dude dude six percent I mean like come
on that's it's never gonna be you're
like next year maybe between five or
years old but next year you were like
interesting yeah it's gonna go up to six
percent I was like it's not gonna go up
to six percent and
um and you were right yeah always right
always right
um what is your um vision for the future
yeah I'm like really happy with
everything that everything that we're
doing now I always want to grow and and
improve vision for the future I mean I
I'd love to have a development company
that was I mean really we're toying and
development you know when you compare us
to people like you look at the big boys
Taylor like everything else we've ever
done I've always been like one of the
best we're definitely not one of the
best development companies there are
people out there that are
killing it right we're just small fry at
the moment in the world of development
so I'd love to have a development
company that was
sort of systemized turning out you know
doing loads of big sites going like
Taylor wimpy or something like that I
mean that would be the thing is it's all
about how you compare yourself to in it
like our family look at us and see like
you know oh you made a million quid last
month on that deal you just bought a
piece of land and got planning and made
1.3 million oh you're like the most
successful people ever but then you're
saying yeah we're really small fry it
just shows how big you are as a thinker
yeah I think it's a massive industry
though like when I look at the
entertainment industry that we're in for
example we were the biggest well we've
got the biggest training company or the
biggest training company I'm used to
being the biggest development we're not
and it pisses you off it doesn't piss me
off I'm very happy with what we're doing
I think we're doing really well but it
just I'm like wow there's so much room
for growth what were your final words of
wisdom and advice for people watching
this that want to maybe get into
property I would say I think property is
the best investment if you look at the
some of their times rich list and you
can actually search by category and you
can see I think it's 40 of them are in
property I think it's a fantastic
industry I think now is a brilliant time
my big negative eyes would be learn all
the different strategies and have your
eyes open so you're in there you've got
a toolbox ready to use when you can spot
the opportunities don't be afraid to
take risks and think big Russell thank
you for a very valuable interesting
interview thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]